c'est vraiment difficile pour moi encore
de témoigner de ce qui est arrivé est
favorable at il dit mais il
tanya st jean avec quatre ans quand elle
a subi son premier viol
les agressions qui ont duré plusieurs
années étaient perpétrés par quatre
proches qu'elle n'a jamais osé dénoncer
à la justice
je vais pas refaire tout à fait que
celle de sortir de mon silence puis de
d'expliquer que de nommer les gens qui
de nommer mes agresseurs puis donne en
mille le de témoigner de façon détaillée
de ce que j'aime hic pour tania la
sphère ghomeshi a permis à lui les
victimes de sortir du silence qui les
ont prises honey elle a cofondé un
collectif qui encourage la guérison par
l'expression artistique
mais entre parler pour mieux guérir et
poursuivre son agresseur
il y en eut pas que la très grande
majorité ne franchira jamais sur 1000
cas d'agression sens ont rapporté 30
vont en procès d'hier seulement sur 1000
reçoive une peine d'emprisonnement
qu'est ce qui pourrait convaincre tania
de poursuivre ses agresseurs c'est les
peines étaient adéquates et
satisfaisante pour pour les réparations
dans un processus de guérison au centre
des victimes d'agression sexuelle de
montréal
on reçoit les appels 24 heures sur 24 7
jours sur 7 dans les deux mois suivant
la sphère ghomeshi et les campagnes sur
les réseaux sociaux
il y a eu un surplus d'appel mais la
proportion de victimes qui décide de
porter plainte
n'augmente pas les gens par ses parents
de se rendre dans un poste de police ou
de venir dans un organisme de dire j'ai
besoin de raconter quelque chose est ce
qu'on voit croire à les ont très très
peur depuis cru selon statistique canada
les crimes violents au sud est de 28% au
pays de 2004 à 2014 pendant la même
période le nombre d'agressions sexuelles
resté stable et contrairement à ce qu'on
croit les victimes ne rapporte pas
davantage les viols en fait la
proportion des cas rapportés a baissé à
5 % et même si tu portes plainte c'est
pas toi qui décides l'heure si la
victime elle pas elle raconte son
histoire et ensuite on y va
son dossier ans et les politiques évalue
ensuite si les procureurs la couronne et
ça veut pas dire parce que tu as porté
plainte que ça va se rendre devant les
tribunaux
et c'est lent c'est peut-être parce que
la justice leur semble inaccessible que
tant de victimes optent pour le tribunal
des réseaux sociaux
petit à petit on voit des progrès on
voit des prises de parole je pense que
ça a été très bénéfique
le hashtag bin ouais pts 9 rbds reporter
a reçu plus de 8 millions de tweets mais
les centres d aide aux victimes du
québec n'ont pas eu plus de demandes
qu'avant d'affaires vos machines ici ce
filon joie radio-canada moria